عبر حساباتهم على منصه تويتر بدا موظفوها
الواحد تلو الاخر وفي مواقع جغرافيه
مختلفه الاعلان عن فقدان وظائفهم بعد
اسبوعين من استحواذ الملياردير ايرون ماسك
على تويتر سرح المئات ليلغي اقساما
بكاملها في كانت الشركه خسرت ايرادات ضخمه
بعيده سحب او تجميد شركات اعلاناتها في ظل
مخاوف وحاله عدم يقين من التوجه الجديد
لتويتر
ماسك
الى ضغوط جماعات ناشطه اتهمتها بمحاوله
تدمير حريه التعبير في امريكا لكنه رغم
موجه التسريح بدا متفائلا
واعتقد انها في النهايه ستكون من اكبر
الشركات قيمه حول العالم
وقبل ايام من استحقاق الانتخابيه مفصليا
في الولايات المتحده رفع هذا الزلزال الذي
هز احدى اكثر من الصوت التواصل الاجتماعي
نفوذا حده القلق خصوصا في اوساط القائمين
على الحملات الانتخابيه من انتشار معلومات
مضلله واخرى تحض على العنف السياسي دون
رقابه كافيه على المحتوى كما حدث الرئيس
التهامي تويتر بنشر الاكاديمي حول العالم
وبالرئيس السابق باراك اوباما التهامي
وسائل التواصل بالتربحي من النزاعات
لا يعملون على الجميع
والخوف من بعضنا البعض لمصلحتهم الشخصيه
حتى يتمكنوا من الوصول الى السلطه وكل هذا
يتم تضخيمه على مدار الساعه من قبل وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي التي قررت انه من
المربح الترويج للجدل والنزاعات والمؤمرات
بدلا من نشر الوقائع والحقيقه
وكانت تويتر ومنصات اخرى للتواصل
الاجتماعي وبعد ضغوط وانتقادات على مدى
سنوات قد وضع الضوابط خصوصا بعيده
لانتخابات الرئاسيه الماضيه واحداث اقتحام
الكونجرس لكبح اي محتوى مضلل او يحض على
العنف كما يهدف الى الغاء الحسابات
المزيفه
مكاتب باتت مهجوره خسائر تقدر بالملايين
وحاله من الفوضى وقعوا يفرض اسئله عما اذا
كانت هذه الميصه وصلت الى خواتمها اما انه
مخاض يفتح فصلا جديدا في عمرها في سنه ابو
كويك الجزيره سان فرانسيسكو كاليفورنيا